as Dan mentioned i have mentioned record
with semen associates were a boutique
investment bank focus on providing
services to startup companies partner
helping the salt form their exit
strategy people and you know situations
where they're also raising capital
assistant person capital we also operate
an early stage venture fund so we're
also investors in space like to
introduce here peter from amazon web
services they voluntarily experience
could be able to a bedroom or so no the
background before was pretty accurate
I've been in corporate development for
about 15 years currently amazon
previously into its and TeleNav which is
a mobile application space and maturely
my career was a very much like Dan but
then I decided to make an honest living
say so for computer my first question to
you is because you know you've seen it
up for startups and have a part of rare
cards in the past both an Amazon Web
Services and companies like into it
until it out you know what sort of a
mattress you look for when you're
evaluating and whether a company is a
proper acquisition target for your own
and a pre group so the way it went on
the corporate side if you're looking at
buying a company it really depends on
what problem you're trying to solve
that's what in that position is all
about so for some companies they use
acquisitions to drive growth if their
growth is small then let's say okay what
is up new space that I want to get into
webbing and accelerate my growth you're
going to be buying a customer base in a
revenue stream and established business
for some companies you're just trying to
accelerate your product development so
that's much more likely the team and
technology and it might be smaller it
may not have any revenue at all for
others it might just be a distribution
channel too
customer set so you know if you're a
company that made that's talking to a
potential acquirer the first thing in
your mind should always be what is the
problem that I'm solvent what's what's
the thing that I bring to this company
that they don't already have because
that's where the conversation is really
really sending around so there's many
answers to that question and it really
depends on what the dynamics are so just
as an example in case of Amazon Web
Services and I think anybody that
operates at a texter knows who they are
but yes for what's our opportunities are
you guys looking at it right now well
that's that's a perfect example so the
nice thing about EWS is we have the
whole resources and Amazon behind us so
in theory we give right 500 million
billion dollar check it out it's working
too hard but if you think about the
scope of Italy was the customer base we
have revenue growth we have already 18
months on a product roadmap for us is
worth so much more than 20 million 30
million 59 so a large majority of things
we look at our tech and team buys that
are going to help us accelerate we're
looking to do now that's it there are a
number of different areas in IT where we
still go touch today and so we'd
recognize that if there's a certain
class of IT spend that we're not
bringing that we're not addressing today
we recognize we have to pay up for that
but a company like EWS not going to
spend money in revenue growth would
probably not spend money on a customer
base we'd likely either find
technologies that we can put into our
distribution channel or we'd find an
area that we don't address today at all
and do something marcin that way I'm
curious I mean and when you do identify
that position target the
you eventually determine it was you know
the next best thing since sliced bread
you have to have it how do these
companies come on your radar map to
begin with how would you buy serves that
are perhaps contemplating exit
strategies how do they get on your radar
right it doesn't have to be just a
moment sir Sir to be you know if you can
provide up examples from some of your
earlier to be sure till it out right so
there's a lot of different ways and so
one way is that you hire skilled kind
like dan and say hey we've got a company
that nobody knows that's exactly why I
asked where a company that nobody knows
about who would be help them should help
them think through who are the right
acquires oftentimes companies are not
sold on their blog and so in fact more
frequently well over half the time it's
well over half the time a company will
be acquirer will approach a company that
they're already working with already
know because the fact is if I'm amazon
and there's a company that can add value
to us chances are there some business
relationship that we can have that sort
of M&A that can be productive there can
be an oem relationship there can be a
licensing deal there can be some kind of
go to market strategy together and
amazon is very aggressive in trying to
build out or an ecosystem one reason is
because people that build on our on our
platform are adding a lot of value but
also because the more companies we know
the more we see who's successful the
more you look forward to looking at so
for a start-up for a smaller company
what that means is building of your
partnership is valuable not just from a
revenue generation point of view but
also building those relationships that
may turn into an exit later on so what
about you know we were just talking
about when you were at telling
the opposition to come from think year I
brought it up just because you know our
firm puts on these monthly dinner events
and we invited entrepreneurs were based
in Santa Monica us when we invite launch
pearson and santa monica seen quite a
bit miss dinner events and i was
actually sitting right next to CEO of
this company that was acquired metallica
two weeks prior to the other position
and I killed myself or not yeah because
I was like here it's like to feel like
you know your way over it it sounds like
how did he enter into your radar how
could you how did that happen could you
just kind of describe that's an
interesting story so for those pick up
no thinking year was a mobile
advertising company that focused on
location-based advertising their
original idea had been to help
restaurants fill seats so the original
idea was hey you know if I Joe's meets a
reader's pizza and if it's raining out I
can send ads to people with their phones
at lunchtime and direct them to my
restaurant who is in the early days of
location-based advertising what they
quickly learned is while restaurant love
that idea because they wanted more
customers there was not enough people
there were plenty of people with phones
but not enough places where they could
put those ads so they can sign up
restaurants all day long but there's no
one that they can send the attitude
because not enough not enough in each
views had location attached to them so
they decided instead of stalling a
restaurant problem of getting the people
near me they wanted to solve the problem
aggregated inventory location the way at
the reason I give that history is
telling that knew that mobile
advertising was going to be important
they knew they wanted to be in a
business and I thought about this whole
question of doing great go to
restaurants or what do we do so I've met
the CEO what he was trying to serve his
restaurants in this way and it was a
mildly interesting
and we are difference it was just a
random eating and then nine months later
they had pivoted away from the
restaurant idea and more toward the
account aggregation where they're
filtering mobile ad impressions by
location and therefore servicing other
people that wanted to generate
advertising campaigns in this way and so
a company that we met and said that
you're only mildly interesting but we
stayed in touch with became dead onto a
readout radar screen and the reason is
where as originally they weren't solving
our problem I hear later they were
solving our problem precisely so this
was an area where just a part of my job
corp development anybody like me is
meant to have antennae all the time
speaking to venture capital is speaking
to bankers and speaking to companies and
this was one of those areas where a line
you put out a year before turn into
something productive I guess the advice
that you'd probably have to start
upstairs a you never know when a
strategic partner for guy was on light
or think telling on the in space might
change corporate priority that's right
what would I want to be clear they
changed their proper positioning not
because of any input we need them just
because they recognize them heat the
market and that hasn't happened that
change in vivid was precisely aligned
with what we want to do now as startup
executives your most impressively
precious resources time and so you don't
want to spend so much time on meetings
that are not directly productive but if
there's companies that might be partners
or might be acquisition that require
can't is down the road those tend to be
productive conversations and so I'd
encourage you to either have yourself
for people on your staff manage those
conversations because those are
important relationships so now there's a
pivoted in a start-up business model
yeah should be taken as an event or an
opportunity to update absolutely refused
partner like acetone in this case we're
all I think
exactly right in fact when we first
spoke to think near it was very much
about hey how can we partner to solve
this problem and the space of a few
weeks we realized melon acquisition make
no sense but anytime you do a pivot it's
not just about what is the new product a
new customer set but there's a likely to
be a complete solution that includes not
just your own resources but who are the
partners in that ecosystem that you're
going to work with together so that
needs to be thought through anytime
you're pinned in your source so I just
wish to bed a little bit now and ask you
your view of the current M&A market as
we all know it's a bit crazy out there
with Facebook by what Sam for 19 billion
that was just a couple weeks later that
they bought oculus for just a little bit
less billion you know and then you have
companies like uber erasing 250 million
last year and then Airbnb Brisbane 500
just one skillet and with review of the
marketplace right now is this you know
is this you know the internet bubble
want my no movie replaying again or who
you know what's your view of market so
for those that were working back in 99
2000 it does feel a lot like that some
ways in terms of the dollar values made
there's a big difference though which is
that all of these companies are you
describing our real businesses not going
to speak to oculus for example I don't
know anything about that that seems
ludicrous but will grow area but over
air B&B these are all companies that
have real revenue and are adding real
value and I think one of the things
that's happened is a pmos going to take
a little bit of credit what's happened
in the early days was you could be very
capital efficient as a start and what
used to cost 5 10 15 look to scale you
need to spend tens of millions of
dollars on hardware in order just to be
able to service these customers now what
happens as customers get direction they
can start ramping up revenue and ramping
up their operations much more
they have a good one too and so what
happens is because the barrier of entry
has gotten so low that means the value
of speed has gotten even higher and so
if you're in a competitive market and
get like uber there's half a dozen other
ride sharing applications up out there
as well if you're an opportunity to grab
a bunch of land and establish a credible
business people are taking advantage of
that because you know the dollars in I'm
turning into dollars out very very
quickly and it really did the bubble
dollars in turned into users that may or
may not turn into dollars out what in
the future today if you think about
again uber Airbnb all these companies
dollars in turns into dollars often so
fast and so the value and the return to
scale is so high that people are betting
on winters with their it is a fair to
say because you know the cost to start
up a start-up an analyst come so low
that you know you sort of a company you
don't see from the traction and try to
find another partner however changing to
address until you find traction yeah
which would be evidence by pcs throwing
money at you growing the business today
I would I want to say that I wouldn't
call feces for my money the metric of
successes but I mean you know is that
sort of what's happening at started
playing these days it really depends
mean I think there are certain markets
plan once you hit growth and growth
becomes explosive in fact ways that you
have no impossible before there are also
plenty of places where slow and steady
wins the race and you know it's just
enterprise sales for example you know
you need to continually working on it I
think nobody ever heard of whatsapp
until you know six months a year before
the acquisition and they were one of the
users like like no one ever never seen
so I wouldn't necessarily be impatient
if you're in a market and not finding
success if you're convinced that there's
a problem they can convince you at the
solution then it's just a question of
iterating on what you'll find the right
product market fit that said you know if
you altima come with the conclusion your
idea is not the
I think there's a more fruitful
opportunity nearby it's when you find
that evidence that you've got the right
solution and then you're starting to see
traction the return on the ink of the
dollars in that point are so good that's
why you see 20 50 100 million dollar
aliens because you can see with six
months of evidence or quarters worth of
evidence that you found the formula
that's what people are really reacting
to so as I'm a banker and your former
banker you know we all know that we'll
see transactions like whatsapp for
oculus and it will say you know one in a
million right i mean you know if every
day could be like that we don't be
fabulously wealthy but we all know that
99% of ebony activities is really not
anything nearly as exciting you know
doubles and triples at best ever I guess
a question for you regarding as does
that mean that you know if you exit out
you know just a double tight about call
or triple chemicals any lesbians and I
was painful I think all depends on why
did you get started why did you start
the company in what are your goals right
I think there's the people that have the
bragging rights private jet counter I
guess that's one metric but you know
most of us have long careers so there
are plenty of people that have one sink
in one success that's moderately
successful but you generate some returns
for VCS and then you've had that
experience and you can go can fund it
again so I'm working on an acquisition
for AWS right now which is you know
relatively small deal it's a soft
landing but the VCS are going to get
their money back the founders arrogance
of money and hopefully they'll stay
amazon for a while and you know the
thing to think about in acquisition is
unless there's some kind of life
changing things a month after the
acquisition you're still going to work
and so you have to define success not
just by the none of the zeros of your
bank account but did you do what you set
out to do in this particular case
there's a pretty decent chance that
this company's product is going to get
to thousands and tens of thousands of
customers Sunday and so that can be very
rare than working not everybody who work
for up what's happening let me pivot
here prove it sorry and as an ask you a
personal question I can yeah we talked
about how you started as a banker and
eventually transition over to the
corporates of it how did you get to
business just kind of curious myself so
my first job out of Yale is kind of
avoid like as I think about what I was
like as a senior you were like words
can't begin to describe the lack of a
clue that I had as a senior in college
so I kind of fell into I was fortunate
to have a technical degree but no honey
I didn't have a job lined up yet and
there was a VC firm that had had an
analyst take another job and they were
looking around I happened to be at the
right place at the right time and so
this is very exciting this is in 1993
these jobs are very hard to come by and
a one can work was very interesting on
the other hand i hated going to work
every day because the people the firm
hated each other so it's a really toxic
environment and so while the work was
interesting it was just uncomfortable
and unpleasant to be at work but so soon
episode after few years there I
important to start up inside spark
actually behaving working environmental
technology on and then going to business
school I came out to California to
Berkeley and so my first job out of
business school was in banking and that
seems to me like the right combination
of technology which is still light banan
switch I had had four and then strategy
as well because acquisitions tend to be
strategic questions for the most part
you know there's a lot of lot of details
that need to be managed but these are
strategic questions about what you want
to do so it was a really good fit for a
for 27 year old coming out of school and
so I came back to get to the lack of
local I think I kind of fell
two in each step of the way I'd never
really was able of 5-10 years ahead but
I kept doing things that seem like they
would be fun and so far you know people
still willing to hire me so it works out
pretty well at this point we can
probably open it up to the audience for
some questions yeah we could actually
probably got time for one mush I'm sorry
Charlotte that it's a good discussion
anybody we just completely before you
guys out there yes it notes a real good
question every company looks at it
different I can't speak to people like
Google or Intel which are really
prolific but I can speak to amazon for
example an investment will take 12 for
us one would be a company that's doing
something interesting that we think will
have applicability in the medium term
two or three years but we're not willing
to bet on yet but we wanted that on
someone else's resources and hard work
that will take that that'll take that
form right another thing that will
happen even if that's not the case is
there's likely to be some business
relationship in the short or the medium
term and so the investment is meant to
support the other business relationship
as people do OEM or joint development
relationships all day so usually an
investment is in support of that and one
way another if there's additional funds
that need to happen or if there's
acceleration that needs to happen amazon
tends to look at it it's in search of a
larger purpose i think google scenes
tends to take a more and intel to we're
feeding the ecosystem and that's all to
our greater good but we tend to be more
targeted and tactical any other
questions on integration me personally
or Amazon my brother
so post-acquisition so amazon has done
I'd say on average five or six steals a
year so the company is relatively good
at it we don't do huge things like
Google Facebook or we Jenna do regular
and there is a whole team within the
corporate development department that is
the integration team they're actually
the same as the diligence to you in fact
so the people that are driving that
process are driving it with an eye
toward how it's going to be integrated
some companies like Zappos are left
alone and want to maintain the brand and
some are integrated in this one that I'm
working on right now is going to be
audio you know just to be part of the
technical team of AWS very very quickly
the bigger the company the more more
customers they have the more likely you
are successful doing their own thing but
for smaller companies you want to have
part of the company part of your core
team as quickly as possible great so
that's it for time I want to thank Dan
and Peter for coming out and speak